foreign
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute but let's do it in a way that
makes the snowflakes heads explode let
me be clear before this podcast begins
we are loud
proud
and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony [ __ ] them
[Music]
friday
hello friday
how are you
[Music]
queen elizabeth past
charles
the third will take the throne and right
wingers are freaking out because he
believes in climate change
that's what they're worried about the
game believes in claims i don't know i
don't know much about the monarchy to be
quite honest with you we talked about
this yesterday um i don't think you have
to [ __ ] on the monarchy but it's just
something that we don't understand here
in this country it's very confusing
there's a few on fox news that would
love for this
to be a monarchy this morning and
there's maga republicans
all around the country that would love
for this to be a monarchy and put their
orange deity at the throne
but it doesn't seem like that's going to
happen
it does not seem like that's going to
happen the wave is happening the wave is
happening we are just two months away
two months away folks
from saving our democracy once again in
the next election because that is how it
is going to feel for many years to come
that we have to push and push and push
every single election
to save our democracy and save our
country from these maga fascists these
america first let's go brandon nazis
that's what we have to do we have to
lean into democracy we have to engage in
our ballot but i am very confident here
one reason why is because it's friday
and
and you know here on the johnny michaels
podcast on friday we who do bonehead of
the week
and our winner just may just may
have had a perp walk yesterday i don't
want to give the game away but i think
you guys already
know it's not hard to figure out who won
boat end of the week this week
oh man what a great image
what a great image
people been calling for it oh there
won't be any justice they won't serve
any time
let me get a perp walk yesterday not
only that it's he's such a [ __ ]
little [ __ ]
steve bannon is such a whiny little
[ __ ]
and his buddy trump is right behind him
they're making all kinds of excuses
all kinds of excuses about these
classified documents down at mar-a-lago
well maybe just maybe he was the
president i don't know maybe just maybe
he
waved his big mac hand
stained hands over the documents and
declassified them oh that's that's a bad
thing well maybe just maybe these aren't
actually classified nuclear secrets
maybe the cia
posts them on their website and he just
took the ones that they posted on their
website
for souvenirs
well
okay he owns them now he hasn't owned
them
he doesn't own the documents there are
documents well maybe maybe they planted
evidence that i mean it just it's never
ending
and the moral of the story here is he's
[ __ ] he's completely [ __ ]
he stole our clocks top secret
classified documents
he had a motive for stealing them trump
doesn't do anything without mo are you
[ __ ] [ __ ] me
you think this guy just gathered up a
bunch of [ __ ] off the floor stuffed it
in a box and took it down to mar-a-lago
with him and it just happened just
happened to be top secret documents
that had human assets and four nuclear
secrets are you get the [ __ ] out of here
with that nonsense you were so full of
[ __ ] [ __ ]
you are such a [ __ ] bonehead if you
believe that nonsense no that is not
what happened just like
steve bannon took his trump supporters
money to build a wall that's [ __ ]
nonsense
no one would ever believe that that
steve bannon actually took this money in
good faith of course he didn't he
stuffed it in his own [ __ ] pockets
and he paid off the people who was
helping him collect the money stuffing
it in their [ __ ] pockets
come on
come on now
and just because the former guy grandpa
poopypants the cheeto dust mobster
pardons him from the federal crimes the
state of new york says nope sorry [ __ ]
that pardon doesn't work here
so i wonder
because we surmised in the title
that they're going to jail and our cute
little thumbnail
thanks to gabe sanchez our co-host and
executive producer
you would think maybe they'd be
cellmates i mean it is possible think
about this this is possible
we can make this possible america this
is something that can maybe maybe just
maybe
we give them their own prison reality tv
show who wouldn't love to watch
steve bannon and donald trump be cell
cellmates in a new york state prison
from their trip from rikers all the way
to the pen
who wouldn't love to see that i'd watch
the [ __ ] out of that content
i'd watch the [ __ ] out of that content i
don't know i'm just pitching here maybe
if the maybe if the cheeto dust mobster
is watching he loves reality tv so much
and he loves to be pitched reality tv
shows i mean his entire [ __ ]
presidency was a reality tv show the
campaign the presidency and now
now his his [ __ ] failed retirement
it's all reality tv show a trumpster
fire
so maybe just maybe we could get cameras
inside rikers with these two and maybe
just maybe we could follow them all the
way to the state the new york state pen
i don't know i'm just saying
that i think it's a good idea
now rick wilson is trending again this
morning for the video from yesterday
and
of course donald trump lost his mind
yesterday threatening to sue the lincoln
project get this hair going here
uh did they stay
grandpa poopy bands threatened to sue
the lincoln project
yesterday
on fraud social and rick wilson clapped
back and basically challenged him he
said come on bring it on [ __ ]
and we played it here on d20 michael's
podcast we reacted to it we posted it on
over on youtube so don't forget to
subscribe to youtube
because boy if you missed the show don't
worry we've started posting each segment
in our youtube channel so that way you
can see every single one of them so
don't forget to subscribe
to the tony michaels podcast here on
youtube and don't forget to follow at
tonymichaelspot on twitter
because today's bonehead of the week and
you get to vote every thursday for
bonehead of the week you'll see if
you're a new viewer today you'll see
what bonehead of the week is in the
second hour
because we do two hours every single
weekday
two of them monday through friday noon
eastern 11 central nine pacific on
youtube twitter and twitch and
simulcasting on facebook
you can watch us here you can also
download every single episode
on apple spotify google but it's friday
is a special day new viewers friday is a
special day because we go through your
vote
for bonehead of the week you vote you
decide who is the bonehead of the week
and we break down your vote this is
democracy folks and we must practice
every single week voting now you never
really vote for one of these son of a
[ __ ] at the polls
that's worth a laugh
and it's worth
practicing your democracy so you can
vote on youtube or twitter for bonehead
of the week follow us subscribe each one
of those places follow us there you will
get to vote each week and we will break
it down as we will today
in the second hour of the show
but i'm gonna do this because it doesn't
afford us much time for serving the
tweety tweets and trendy trends and you
know
you know here on the tony michaels
podcast that we love to surf the tweety
tweets and the trendy trends that is
what we live for there's a ton of new
clip
that we have to get to this morning
they're gonna try to cancel peppa pig
have you seen this these [ __ ]
homophobic bigots
they're terrified of peppa pig
i'm not [ __ ] you remember when they
were yelling and screaming
about canceling a [ __ ] eminem
they're like oh
eminem is changing
how they draw the green eminem
and they're freaking out mr potato head
changed the word on their box
remember that
freaking the [ __ ] out it's cancer
culture
you goddamn liberals
you're gonna destroy our economy with
your can't whatever the [ __ ] they were
saying i don't know they're [ __ ]
boneheads
they're gonna cancel peppa pig
because there's two mommies on the i'm
not [ __ ] you there's two mommies on
peppa pig apparently and they're
freaking out about it they're [ __ ]
freaking out
as if you wouldn't just walk around in
the world and
see two mommies you know holding hands
down the sidewalk or
hamming chill i mean this is not [ __ ]
weird stuff
your children
it just doesn't have to be weird you're
the weirdos you're the ones that are
focused on who people are having sex
with and who people love
and people's genitalia everyone else
just wants to watch
[ __ ] peppa pig and have a good time
so here's what we're gonna do because
i've got a ton of video to get to
stick around we'll be right back right
after these messages with the [ __ ] list
roundup where we surf the tweety tweets
in the trendy trends don't go anywhere
we'll be right back
we'll be right back
mark
60 seconds this is the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
i've always wanted to learn a new
language but whenever i try it never
sticks so when babel made a mag edition
i knew i had to give it a try babel maga
edition makes it really easy to learn
and there's lots of lessons to choose
from like subtly racist to full-blown
white supremacists the first lesson
began with learning simple phrases and
soon i was putting those words and
phrases into a conversation each lesson
takes about 10 to 15 minutes to complete
and they're all really different which
keeps things interesting the app is
really smart it actually keeps track of
the words that i'm struggling with i
chose battle mag edition because it's
created by smart white people like me
and now i can't wait to explore meet new
friends and use my new maga skills with
my in-laws all lives matter
jumping back into it this is the tony
michaels podcast
welcome welcome welcome welcome back to
the show
it's friday
friday
friday
he's excited that it's friday
end of the week in the second hour
we shortened the a block today i
shortened it it's usually about 30
minutes long but here we are about 15
minutes in
and we're going to go surf the tweety
tweets and training trends because i
have i got a ton of stuff to get to
before we get to bonehead because we got
a ton of stuff to talk about in bonehead
of the week
we got a ton of stuff to talk about in
bone and we have plenty of [ __ ] bone
hens as we always do in this country
with these maga republicans he's fascist
yeah plenty of bone headachery
and you know that bone end of the week
plays here live in the second hour of
the tony michael's podcast but we cut it
we clip it and we play it over on the
midas touch network
every friday evening so don't forget
to watch the replay of the bonehead of
the week over on the midas touch network
so we'll get to that here at the top of
the hour we're about 45 minutes away or
so
from bonehead of the week
but i want to surf the tweety tweets and
trendy trends you guys know we do the
shitless roundup here every single
weekday and that is very important for
you to stay
educated
on what these morons are doing and what
these morons are saying and how they
want to take our way our democracy
and boy do i have a couple videos that i
want to show you that i definitely want
to get to before we get to bonehead of
the week i don't want to miss this this
is super important for you to keep your
eye on the ball here and not look away
because they're trying to steal away
your democracy and they're trying to
take away peppa pig and [ __ ] bastards
let's do this let's surf the tweety
tweets and trendy trends start the
countdown
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the [ __ ] list
welcome welcome welcome back to the tony
michaels podcast we've reached the part
of the show the shitless roundup where
we round up all the tweety tweets and
trendy trends uh boy do we have uh some
crazy video for you today there's one
specifically i want to show you real
quick here um believe it or not cnn
hasn't fallen all the way by the wayside
they must have had this one in their
pocket before they took a turn for trump
um but it really it really does spell
um
hard hard hard stuff for the fascists in
this country it really exposes them it
shows what they're actually doing and
they're not just doing it in one state
and folks i've been [ __ ] saying this
i've been telling you this and doubt me
on this i even tweeted it here
there won't be a civil war there they
will steal your democracy away from the
inside that is exactly what they plan on
doing that exactly what they want that's
why steve bannon needs to be in [ __ ]
handcuffs in a jail cell because him
yapping his trap and convincing these
people to do this is what is happening
doubt me doubt me on it there's not
gonna be no [ __ ] civil war
they're not going to win by doing
violence in the streets where they're
going to take over a country in each
[ __ ] county each election office
every single state come on give me a
[ __ ] break what they're trying to do
is they're trying to steal our elections
from the inside
you know that [ __ ] they talk about how
democrats stole the 2020 election they
rigged it that's what they're doing
that is what they're trying to do folks
[ __ ] delusional
and it's dangerous as [ __ ] and i'm not
talking about violence and riots and the
[ __ ] they're trying to distract us with
to try to scare you about a bunch of
[ __ ] gravy seals
going rogue in the streets that's not
what i'm talking about i'm talking about
them actually stealing your [ __ ] way
of life away from you stealing your
[ __ ] freedom because that's what
they're doing they're trying to steal
your freedom and every american's
freedom along with it watch this report
from cnn new day
i know i know cnn has taken a turn here
but they must again they must have had
this reporting racked up before they
really started to go full on trump
because this does not spell trump and
maybe our pushback
the last few weeks
has led them to air this this story
watch
now to a cnn exclusive video showing
election workers being trained by
republican leaders in michigan to break
the rules so they can act as quote
undercover agents during the midterm
elections in november you heard that
right
you heard that right they're training
republicans maga republicans
to be secret agents to be spies
i'm not [ __ ] [ __ ] you here they
say it out loud this it's not like this
is [ __ ] some kind of conspiracy
theory these people are holding meetings
and discussing and zoom [ __ ] calls
how to steal our elections
through the
elections these people have lost their
goddamn minds watch drew griffin joins
us live with this cnn investigation this
is incredibly alarming drew
doubly troubling brianna because this
becomes amid a big nationwide push by
this ultra mega crowd to get involved in
the election the people who didn't
believe the last election was fair for
some reason still are now getting
involved in running this election which
is why what you're about to see is
troubling
well don't be fearful guys cnn obtained
this recording of a wayne county gop
training session over zoom the night
before the michigan primary last month
agents congratulations just undercover
training
they're undercover agents
they're having a [ __ ] zoom call where
they're talking about people watching
election officials and they're
undercover agents they're there to
destroy
they're there to thwart
your democracy your vote this is your
vote they're [ __ ] talking about
this is real life [ __ ] this isn't
[ __ ]
wrestling this isn't [ __ ] football
this isn't the goddamn baseball game
this is real [ __ ] life
and these people are coming after the
lgbt community that in tennessee they
want to marry your [ __ ] children
they're coming after women's rights and
freedoms everywhere including to their
body and to their medical decisions
and it won't stop there it'll go to
contraception it'll go to men's
contraception it'll go to what religion
you can and cannot have doubt me
doubt me
and they're trying to work this is the
civil war folks this is it
ain't no [ __ ] there ain't gonna be no
fat dudes with ar-15s in the streets
gonna take over our government you
[ __ ] [ __ ] me
you think a bunch of gravy seals have
any chance against our military against
our country you are a dumb [ __ ]
if you think that's where this is
happening they're trying to steal your
[ __ ] government and they're doing it
from the inside
it gets worse i'm telling you it gets
way worse it is extra training partisan
training not just for volunteers
observing elections but including the
actual paid election workers who will
check in voters hand out ballots even
help in the county which is that's right
the people that are going to count your
[ __ ] vote are being trained
how to overthrow a government how to
overthrow an election
on zoom calls
they're organizing and training traitors
that's what they're doing this isn't
democracy
this is them using our vote to take away
our democracy to use the election system
to take away our democracy the way they
do in russia
they act like they got some kind of
[ __ ] election system in russia
there's no goddamn election system in
russia
it's all for show that's what they want
to do they want to have it for show and
exactly what mike lindell
michael flynn sydney powell
donald trump and the rest of those
[ __ ] mogollonites have been accusing
democrats of doing
that's what they're currently doing
that's what they're doing it's all
projection and they're doing it right
now they're trying to get inside those
elections
and i know it feels like oh what what
can we do
you have to lean into your democracy
you can't you can't go oh well my vote's
not gonna count so i'm not gonna go vote
because it definitely won't count if you
don't vote it definitely won't count if
you don't engage if you don't make sure
people are registered if you don't make
sure people go in and use their power of
their voice with their vote
because democrats sure as hell have a
hell of a lot better teams to know what
election laws are
the smart republicans here have left the
[ __ ] party they've left smart
republicans wouldn't engage in state and
federal crimes to try to overthrow
elections they wouldn't do it
if they were smart they're not they're
maga republicans they're [ __ ] cult
members
they're trump lodites moglodites
boneheads
we have good people on our side
in the democrat party
who are going to protect
our vote and try everywhere to protect
our vote but you must
you must engage in your ballot that's
why what they are being told is alarming
there's a lot of bad stuff that's
happening in this upcoming election so
we're gonna have to keep our heads on a
swivel and just start documenting
irregularities look we're not even to
the election yet we're two months away
from it and there's already bad stuff
what the [ __ ] does that mean
there's not even early voting i mean
there will be soon but there's not even
early voting at this point how in the
hell could there be bad stuff happening
in these elections
other than you people trying to
overthrow them before we even vote and
that's what they really want folks
that's what they want they want to
determine these elections before you
even cast a ballot
the poll workers are hired by towns and
clerks and wayne county's republican
chairperson cheryl costantino tells them
they may need to break the rules to
uncover fraud they were told by their
trainers that they could not have their
funds with them though i would say maybe
just hide it and maybe hide a small pad
and a small pen you need to take
accurate notes
so here she is telling them hide your
phones hide your notes because they'll
take them away from you they'll take
them away from you she'll just hide them
just you know don't listen to the rules
don't listen to the rule of law don't
listen to any of that cheat
cheat in your elections that's the only
way we'll win that's what they're saying
here
and these people are buying this stuff
well this guy this next guy doesn't
quite buy it watch take accurate notes
if we are observed with a pen and a
piece of paper writing on anything they
they just said they would they would ask
us that they would remove us
that's right they would remove us
because it's against the rules to do
that you're just observing
you're just watching you're a watcher to
make sure democracy the election workers
aren't doing what you're saying you want
to do
how can they not [ __ ] see the forest
through the trees here it's because
they're in a [ __ ] cult
they're in a [ __ ] cult
and just like we talked with jim
stewards and yesterday they are
absolutely mind [ __ ] here
they're so mind [ __ ] that they got
this whole thing turned around on
themselves
that's why you gotta do it secretly
for the primary was just practice for
the upcoming midterms according to
constantino and it's not just what's
being taught it's who is doing the
teaching this is super important watch
who they're having talk to these [ __ ]
people watch heather who who they're
having mind [ __ ] brainwash these
people into thinking the only way to
make sure your elections aren't stolen
is to steal them yourselves
i'm dead serious listen we think a lot
of the monkey business that's happening
is happening at the vote aggravation
location that is election denier patrick
kobeck who co-led this training session
he's a former state senator who wrote a
book called the 2020 coup and has oh
there was a 2020 coup attempt
there was one
but you [ __ ] got your head so
far up your ass you don't know what
[ __ ] from shinola at this point blog
filled with debunked conspiracy theories
about voting machines he spread so much
disinformation about the 2020 election
he got this cease and desist letter from
dominion the voting machine company
saying you are knowingly sowing discord
in our democracy all the while
soliciting exorbitant amounts of money
all right well first of all he's
appeared on steve bannon's show
okay so right there he's appeared on
steve bannon's trader tv news network
think about that for a second
steve bannon was was arrested and
charged yesterday
with
with fraud
with defrauding the very people that
this guy is defrauding
now you talk about a fraud here's the
next [ __ ] my pillow my slipper nazi
let's watch he's on his [ __ ] [ __ ] too
and with the my pillow guy mike lindell
we did see evidence that it was
connected to the internet there is no no
no
they were not connected to the internet
and it is all [ __ ]
it's all nonsense it's [ __ ] lies and
again the guy sitting next to steve
bannon who steve bannon yesterday was
arraigned on charges in the state of new
york for defrauding the same people this
guy's trying to defraud
it's absolutely batshit crazy
evidence any voting machines were
connected to the internet in the 2020
election but kobeck is still asking
republican poll workers to check there's
this little icon down the bottom right
hand corner and what i'm trying to do is
to see whether or not these machines are
indeed connected to the internet no
you're not that's not what you're trying
to do you're trying to thwart people's
idea that democracy exists
is what they're trying to do folks
they're trying to see if they can
convince not just their supporters but
the entire country or the majority of
the country that democracy doesn't
really exist
because once it's if you believe that
democracy doesn't really exist it's not
a thing then when it's taken from you
it's something you don't miss it's not a
big deal i mean we didn't have democracy
anyways
that's what they're trying to do
from the inside that's where the civil
war is happening not out in the streets
with a bunch of fat dudes and black
jackets
and peashooters no that's not what's
gonna happen this is the civil war
kobeck refused to speak to cnn but the
other leader of the training cheryl
constantino did
this is beautiful here this is words out
of their own [ __ ] mouths this lady
here this lady here is the one who was
telling them to be secret agents to be
spies
to make sure to thwart our democracy
to overturn our elections
is what they're telling these folks on
these zoom calls to do
this is that lady this is her right here
listen to what she says it is [ __ ]
crazy
training these people to be undercover
spies that was the words you were using
and i'm wondering why
well
first of all
if you remember in the election two
years ago
now this lady um
is the chair
she's the chair she's the head of the
wayne county gop in michigan
now the other guy's in atlanta
this just isn't in michigan though folks
you know what they're doing this [ __ ]
right here
tucked away in wayne galley michigan
they're doing it all over the country
and if you think him being on steve
bannon's show is just happenstance that
these [ __ ] steve bannon and
donald trump and the like don't have
something to do with this you're outside
your [ __ ] mind
you're outside your mind
the my pillow guy steve bannon and this
this woman but with the guy
who's telling people who's sewing
anti-democracy discord
throughout the gop
deluding brainwashing mind [ __ ] manga
republicans
into believing
that the [ __ ]
that they're telling them democrats are
doing they're actually convincing them
to do themselves
watch
there were so many problems with
election staffing she said with who
counted ballots but she's an election
denier too she filed a baseless lawsuit
in detroit alleging election fraud in
2020 it was thrown out why did she tell
election workers to act like spies to
kind of reframe it and make it more fun
and interesting
oh it's professional wrestling now again
i say this all the time we are at the
intersection of wrestlemania in real
life these [ __ ] know it they've
got all these people brainwashed into
thinking that it's just all fun and
games
it's not fun and games it's not
this our [ __ ] way of life our entire
country's foundation
is built
on the respective elections the entire
thing
the entire democracy
is built on the foundation that we have
integrity in our democracy integrity in
our vote and yes is there some fraud
some places absolutely we're seeing it
right here in front of your eyes
the gop the maga republicans
the america first nazi party
wants to tear down
your way of life and they want to take
away your democracy because if they can
erode your democracy from within they
can really take away your liberty look
what they did with roe i mean jesus
christ it took him a long time to buy
and pay for all those supreme court
justices but they finally got it done
they finally were able to use our system
of democracy
to take away women's liberty to take
away women's freedom and they won't stop
there they're not going to stop there
i said just you know instead of causing
a bunch of scenes and things like that
just write it down just kind of be like
spies and let me
you know let me know what's going on
what
be like spies gabe sanchez she wants
these people to be like spies and tell
her what's going on in these elections
this is [ __ ] crazy have you watched
it
no i have not seen this god this is nuts
you got to go back and watch this i've
been showing our audience i wanted to
get to this this is cnn reporting this
which is you know regardless of what you
think maybe they had it on the slate
before they took a hard right turn or
maybe maybe just maybe they saw the
pushback from last week they're like ah
that whole maga thing you might not want
to do that and they go against it
we're holding zoom meetings to teach
election workers how to thwart our
democracy they're literally telling them
to be secret agents and spies that's
what they're telling them watch
michigan's primary election went
smoothly i did nothing wrong a poll
challenger affiliated with kobeck and
his training was thrown out of detroit's
ballot counting center for repeatedly
getting too close to workers i told them
that they were breaking the law what's
happening in michigan is happening
across the nation attempts are underway
to make sure the ultra mega run the
election process from poll workers all
the way up to candidates for secretary
of state and attorney general and this
is what i've been saying gabe this is
what i've been saying the civil war is
not in the streets you're not going to
have fat toothless dudes with in trump
hats
beating our military at some sort of
violent overthrow of the government it's
not going to happen we watched this on
january 6th
it's not gonna happen yeah they tried it
their attempt to steal away our
democracy
is inside our government and when steve
bannon is meeting with this guy who's
going on these meetings to tell these
people how to [ __ ] cheat in our
elections it makes me suspicious that
the guy who just got handcuffed for
defrauding trump supporters is teaching
another guy how to defraud trump
supporters and steal our elections at
the same time i'm sorry i'm just trying
to make sense of this so you're telling
me that the people that complain about
people cheating
yeah that's what they want to do yeah
okay okay just want to make sure
projection comes to mind no yeah
it's always i mean you never have to
guess that's the that's the that's the
craziest part about this whole exercise
that we're going through right now in
our country with misinformation
disinformation with mind [ __ ] like we
talked with jim stewart from yesterday
is that it really is right out in the
open like it's obvious that they're
projecting everything that they accuse
democrats of is [ __ ] they wanted to do
and want to do to steal elections
that's exactly what they were telling us
they were like hey if we were to steal
the election
this is how we would do it and how we
plan on doing it like literally that's
what they would do
but you know
who's who's to really point the finger
here no i know no one no one should be
pointing the finger at them because they
right clearly they're the victim tony
right they frankly are the victim you
know and there's no more projection than
ex that exact statement let's let's
continue
trump attorney cleta mitchell has led
seminars in eight swing states all under
the presumption democrats cheat cnn
caught up with her in wisconsin that
we'll be able to
make sure that there's um there's
another set of eyes going on
watching the ballots watching the voting
watching the process knowing what's
going on in the election offices
okay so
hey you know what kalitta mitchell
mitchell is do you remember her name on
the january 6 select hearings
um yeah she was one of the ones she was
one of the attorneys all up in trump's
ear about how you can and can't steal a
democracy i believe kalina mitchell is
from arizona i believe or nevada one of
those states i'm not real sure but here
she is in wisconsin they caught up with
her in wisconsin [ __ ] going
around the country telling people how to
steal elections yes and this is jeff
this is jeff timmer let's let's listen
to his response he used to be the
michigan chair
the same position that the lady who's
telling people to be spies
one of the same types of positions he
was the state chair not the county these
uh training sessions are planned chaos
these people
are being radicalized jeff chimmer used
to lead the michigan republican party
they think they're saving
democracy
from the cannibal socialists where in
fact what they're doing
is
eroding the public's faith in in
elections
brianna secretary of state's
particularly in michigan they're
preparing for whatever might come up but
there is a bright spot in this and
that's from the town clerks that
actually run these elections
they say that most of this election
denialism is coming out of ignorance and
once they get these volunteers and
employees in there even suspicious ones
and they see how the system works they
actually become believers in how we vote
in this country so
hopefully
smell [ __ ] well i mean you know he's
he's trying to make a strong case here
for why why this isn't such a big deal
but it is a big deal yeah and even if
they're pretending because i think
that's what you're saying like they're
like oh yeah sure i believe in it
well they say they believe it and
they're like oh well if they see it then
it's like oh i'm more likely to
participate in the actual process of
voting like the actual act of democracy
and there i i somehow don't believe that
if i were to if i were to look
at a group of people that were
manipulating the votes or manipulating
the outcome or influencing the outcome i
don't know if i would have the most
amount of faith to participate
necessarily like some people might be
like oh [ __ ] this i'm gonna vote but
some people might be like well if
they're already
manipulating or influencing the election
then what am i one person gonna do right
so you know i think this is the actual
um
the disappointment that i have about the
georgia case that they're bringing uh in
in georgia against people who were
trying to to overturn the election there
after the fact um because i think if
more of that would come to light and i
think that's what lindsey graham and
rudy giuliani they're trying to stall
because they know they're not this story
that what happened in georgia isn't
going to come out until after the
election which is good for them because
they can get all these people to commit
crimes for them these people are going
to be committing
crimes on behalf
of the maga republican party i mean it
is bonkers that they are going to be
doing this just like lindsey graham was
willing to allegedly commit crime
giuliani and jenna ellis were running
around the country we we watched as
rusty bowers the arizona
speaker
came to washington and said yeah they
were [ __ ] trying to overturn the
election right and they were doing it
fraudulently they weren't giving me real
information they're just like trust me
overturn it and then we're good yeah
like how many millions of dollars are
wasted in all of these different
counties in states where they had to
recount
for not only
joe biden to show that he actually did
win but to show that joe biden won by
even more votes right like when you when
you begin to count these things like oh
it looks like this was a problem that
was a problem and you find out that
there's actually more votes for joe
biden like how embarrassing is that for
a group of people who think that they're
going to change the outcome of the
election why by either stopping or
continuing their vote right because that
one part of the country they were
stopping they wanted to stop the vote at
the end of the part of the country they
wanted to continue to vote you know it's
just one of those things where
they complain and complain and complain
when it's when it's not in their favor
and most of the time it's not because
they're just the people who are
complaining are the losing group right
and those are the republicans during the
election and they will continue to do
that
up until the point that they win and
there's part of me that says even if
they do win
they'll complain to say well we won by
weight by by more by even more right and
it's like uh
no you didn't
but it's it is projection it is
hypocrisy the group that you know claims
i mean even in that even in the shortcut
that we saw from cnn of the guy who was
like i've got this badge which looked
like a yellow
like note card
fire to say that he's right right
yeah and so it's it's that it's that
effort of like oh we need people to
oversee what's going on it's like oh now
you guys want oversight now you guys
want some sort of regulatory body
involved for everything else when it
comes to the economy or any other policy
you guys don't want any regulation you
don't want any oversight whether it's
the environment it's uh it's how our
financial institutions are are run it's
anything you guys don't want that but
when it comes to election when you can
manipulate the outcome so that you win
oh yeah well [ __ ] yeah man we want we we
want the ability to look over everything
you guys do
well hell yeah they they want well i
mean they want they want free fascist
reign over everything right but here's
the thing the observer thing where
they're trying to train observers to
obstruct
the thing is the reason why they're
doing this is because they had a real
tough time in the 2020 election when
they got into courts
when these observers had to go under
oath and had to tell their stories and
they were like what that's not you know
how that works right that's not how that
works just because you're you're seeing
what you're seeing is not what you think
you're seeing because rudy giuliani is
whispering in your ear and farting on
you yeah that's not what is happening
and and that's where they got really
sideways and that's why they want people
to take notes and to have their cell
phones ready
because they want to have it as evidence
because we're all like show us the
evidence and they're like well there is
none
right but even when they show us the
evidence it's always some
dumb thing they're like oh well look at
this photo or look at this video this
this is not at all what you think it is
well because
that's the whole 2 000 mules they
they they show they show video evidence
of [ __ ] that's
like just normal stuff well they yeah
they're like oh look at this person's
stuff like putting the stuffing the
ballots in the in the ballot box it's
like that that's they're yeah they're
they're putting their ballot in the
ballot box like there's another one oh
we solved a murder because a gps
location no you didn't
no you didn't
well the thing that you guys clinching
was is the box the box vault that they
have inside the counting facility they
stuck it underneath the table they left
and then they they said no we got to
keep counting we can't stop counting so
they go back to resume and they pull it
back out underneath the table and
continue counting and they said that
that was somehow right they're like
they're cheating they're pulling it out
from nowhere and it's like no that was
the one that they had before right right
right right i don't know
no body of people have come
around or in the vicinity of this box
other than the people who just put it in
right and then they said you got to keep
counting until then they took it out
right the same [ __ ] with they had
suitcases of ballots or this this van
showed up and uh in whatever calendar
delivered in the morning delivered
ballots is like where do you think they
collected the ballot right where how do
these people act like do they do they
think they transport these star trek
style or i think so i think it's as soon
as you vote like as soon as you mail
that [ __ ] in it's there well the other
thing too that gets me is they're like
they're connected to the internet
yet they still have to deliver them to
count them what the [ __ ] are you talking
about it's one or the other it's one of
the other you don't get to have it both
[ __ ] ways right but but it that's it
doesn't it's not supposed to make sense
like jim said yesterday it's not really
supposed to make sense the actual the
objective is
is to make it not make sense right that
way it's it's well
it's the same exact tactic that you see
with donald trump
specifically donald trump i mean other
mag republicans will do the same thing
but obviously this is the same type of
approach that they had around propaganda
and the news and the media and we saw
this way back
in world war ii right yet you had hitler
who was saying you can't trust anyone
else you can't trust them you can't
trust them you can't trust them and by
default by saying that you can't trust
all these bodies right all these these
outlets all these news or media stations
or whatever you in turn are the person
that they can trust so now you're like
yeah yeah yeah everything i say is truth
so when i say that's fake and that's
fake and that's made up and that's
mainstream media just trying to
manipulate what i said even though what
i said was exactly what i said
right
it's the same thing it's the same
fascist tactic to say oh no no that's
all [ __ ] don't trust them trust me
and you know and we talked with jim
yesterday about how this whole thing
happened right you got people that are
isolated
online during the pandemic like all of
these factors were perfect in this in
this storm of crazy conspiracy [ __ ]
to manipulate people to make them think
something that they wouldn't otherwise
think if if the conditions were
different
and so it's that same thing of trump and
republicans being like that's fake news
that's fake news can't trust them and by
default it's you can trust me so now
everything i say is the absolute truth
and if anyone says otherwise then they
are the enemy of the state speaking of
fascist
have you seen the pennsylvania mussolini
this [ __ ] guy holy [ __ ]
listen to what this is this is a
masteriano yo you mean the
insurrectionist yeah he is a [ __ ]
traitor but listen
listen to how he describes women's
freedom here
he really it seems like he doesn't like
the idea of women's freedom listen uh i
don't give a way for exceptions either
kathy barnett is going to be our next
next u.s senator she is a product of
rape okay thank you
okay this isn't very long but there's a
lot of [ __ ] packed in these few seconds
here now again this is the
insurrectionist
this is the incorrectness which if if we
go by the judge's decision on coy
griffin the cowboys for trump guy the
commissioner out in new mexico if you go
by that if even if this [ __ ]
wins he'll probably be 14th and he'll be
removed from office because he's an
insurrectionist
but here's the thing
it really gets me that this guy shaves
his head and he looks like mussolini
right yeah i mean come on is this a joke
this is a [ __ ] joke i don't know he
makes me think that he's trying to look
like like bruce willis or something oh
you think
not really pulling it off you think i'm
just willing to play a good mussolini
i'm not trying to think like oh he looks
he looks like my thumb actually he does
kind of look like a [ __ ] thumb didn't
he it's thumb with a tie on but here he
is saying i don't like women to have any
freedom whatsoever even if
their life is in danger because of rape
or incest or just because the pregnancy
goes south and their life is in danger
[ __ ] them they don't get to have freedom
and then he says the senator because i
i'm i'm thinking he's referring to the
republican uh nominee who's gonna get
crushed i don't know who is he talking
about here yeah what is what does he say
who is he saying well we'll watch watch
i don't give away for exceptions either
kathy barnett is gonna be our next next
u.s senator she is a product of rape
okay
kathy barnett is she the one who lost dr
oz is this got up this videos gets to be
old i guess kathy barnett
congressional district pennsylvania for
she's representative
she was running for the u.s senate so
she
so this this is this is but also what
the [ __ ] is that [ __ ] like no idea
look i don't know whether she has come
out publicly and talked about this but
even so
that is not really something that's your
business to like throw that [ __ ] out
there like
if someone's gonna air that out for the
public you know and they do it under
their own terms for whatever the
narrative they're trying to create
that's fine you know they can do what
they want but i feel like it's very much
an overreach of someone's privacy and
personal story and trauma of you know of
going through that that for him just
like oh yeah she's a product of rape
like you think this guy you think this
guy cares about other people's trauma oh
no not at all this guy's like [ __ ] women
[ __ ] their freedom [ __ ] their life i
don't give a [ __ ] no exception no
exception if you're if you're a 12 year
old that was raped by a family member
and you get pregnant you got to carry
that [ __ ] to term right even if
it kills you because there's no
exception you think well they don't he's
a [ __ ] do you think he has any empathy
for anyone else's story come on oh no
not at all no no i i don't i don't think
they do i mean well you know keep in
mind this is mega right this is maggot
that is it's [ __ ] oh my god they
within eight seconds it describes them
perfectly they will make accusations and
most of them are not true right you've
got donald trump at the rallying
pennsylvania goes john fetterman is he
wants to do decriminalize this drug this
drug this drug disrupt and fentanyl
which he also takes like
whoa whoa
okay i don't know the legal side of this
like if you know we've got a former
presence i don't know what protections
he has and i don't know exactly what
freedom of speech he has around that
accusation i mean you can accuse someone
like i can accuse him of overdosing on
adderall which i mean he probably does
but if you say i don't know i mean like
say could you know accusing someone of
being a drug addict is a pretty big
thing especially when that drops junior
is a drug addict yeah well he's a nobody
he's a drug addict yeah so why why
you're saying that i i mean i don't i
actually well here's the difference
there's truth
and there's a lie and i don't know when
you watch donald trump junior with the
booger sugar hanging on like that's true
like hunter biden he has struggled with
drug addiction right right
you know don jr clearly struggled with
drug addiction doesn't want to admit it
but he has right donald trump adderall
we've seen the sudafed uh
photos that are in his desk right just
stash just like he would with this top
secret classified documents
right when you make an accusation though
for someone who's running for office and
say this person does fentanyl
it seems like a big deal to call them a
drug addict especially on a national
stage yeah
it might be but i i actually think i
actually think um the people of
pennsylvania would much rather have uh
uh john fetterman hopped up on fentanyl
than it than some [ __ ] celebrity from
new jersey oh he doesn't know his ass
from a hole in the ground i mean
honestly that if donald trump wants to
put it framing up like that like look
pennsylvania's willing to swing on the
guy who's addicted to [ __ ] fentanyl
rather than the [ __ ] guy who doesn't
know what the hell he's talking about
from new jersey i think that you know
that's not a bad narrative right and
really honestly i don't
i think fetterman's on a lot of
prescription drugs here and the reason
why is because he's had some health
problems and he's trying to get back to
where he can speak he he does not he
doesn't have any mobility problems you
can see that in the videos but he does
still have a little bit of that speech
problems and dr oz really is he's he's
he could take advantage he could
politicize that but he's well he already
tried to right he was like oh if he ate
more vegetables and he would have had a
heart attack and it's like that's not
exactly how that works well try let me
tell you that sending a message going
into pennsylvania and going you can't
eat philly cheese steaks or you'll have
heart attacks like fetterman yeah great
messaging fantastic good luck oh yeah
okay
okay common people of
of pennsylvania i'm sure that's gonna
ring ring with them um speaking of
boneheads
uh trying to keep
things that people like out of their
hands you know people in pennsylvania
don't want to ban philly cheesesteaks
but
you know dr oz does he wants to put
vegetables only on your philly
cheesesteaks but here is
this woman from moms of liberty what a
name moms of liberty of liberty almost
like they don't even know what the word
liberty means
i forget her [ __ ] name here i don't
know her name but this is on this is on
she is she's she's mother liberty and
that's what i'm sure i'm sure she is um
she's talking about peppa pig here you
know they freaked out when eminem's they
changed how they drew a green eminem
remember that yeah yeah we're just gonna
change it i don't remember when tucker
you're gonna ruin our economy because
you're changing how you draw the green
eminem yeah i mean they've changed how
they yeah
again a private company decided to do
something with their own products right
right and then and then you have you
have the mr potato head remember they
found out about that because again
there's a word on the box right change
the word or the logo they change the
logo on the box the character is still
mr potato head but well there is a mrs
potato
how the box looked but the name of the
group is just potato head right it's
just that's what it is there's no mister
on the brand there's a mr character they
never they never took away the [ __ ]
potato spuds dick okay guys right they
never do potatoes have dicks i don't
know i don't know i you know you've got
one of those like you know how they like
grow roots and stuff yeah maybe that's
that's
a potato i don't know i don't know you
know you know who knows ted cruz
they are obsessed with japanese they
probably wouldn't know sesame street
with it [ __ ] obsessed with that well
this [ __ ] mom of liberty this this
[ __ ] she is [ __ ] completely obsessed
with what people do and what how i mean
i can't even imagine
how ted cruz and this lady is so
obsessed with cartoons like they are
obsessed with cartoons i'm like have you
have you went on the internet and
actually watched this anime porn stuff
you're not even you're not even skimming
there also where are you
iceberg here like if anyone else is
bringing it like republicans will be
like oh it's it's it's porn it's anime
porn it's cartoon it's not it's like
this and it's like why are you watching
that other one right well you know why
are you
doing research like josh hawley well ted
cruz is obsessed with mickey [ __ ]
pluto like he can't stop talking about
how mickey [ __ ] pluto you would almost
think you well yeah i've seen him talk
about you know in his in his leather
reclining yeah he's
so disconnected in his elitist form like
every three minutes he brings
this disney porn it's almost like the
way that ted cruz talks about these
other uh inanimate objects because they
are right they're either a cartoon that
is just two-dimensional uh they are a a
toy that is you know
it doesn't [ __ ] move unless you do it
right
you would think that the the you're
talking about are you talking about
action figures are you talking about
something else to other kind of toys
well no any other i know any other toy
oh okay
cruz does not want remember the whole he
tried to ban the dildos well i mean he
wants dildos he just doesn't right
he wants them all for himself bro yeah
yeah yeah i mean
here's the thing
for as much as ted cruz talks about
these other inanimate
uh fiction characters right yeah
you would
you would kind of think that those were
the things that he's running against
like he's running for re-election in the
senate and [ __ ] goofy or mr potato
head or [ __ ] peppa pig like any of
these people or any of these things were
running against him as a u.s senator for
texas that is the impression that i get
from ted cruz for the amount of time
that he's fined so much that he thinks
he's running against mickey i mean
desantis thinks he's running against
mickey yeah but you know let's listen to
the moms of liberty lady here oh my god
you won't believe this [ __ ] when i
watched this this morning i was like
what in the [ __ ] are they talking about
they want they want to get rid of peppa
pig
because
there's two mommies in there i'm not
[ __ ] you this is the reason watch a
good portion of you know peppa pig is
out of great britain but it runs here in
america and a good portion of american
parents have deeply helped beliefs that
conflict with um the things that are
being put out in these cartoons for
toddlers
so change the channel dummy i was just
gonna say the [ __ ]
the great thing here
is it's your body
your choice
your tv okay you can choose whatever you
want to watch in your house if you don't
want to watch peppa pig don't turn it on
if you find that it's on some streaming
network don't pay for that streaming
network i'm sure these companies don't
give a [ __ ] about what you pay for and
what you don't pay for so you people
have tv freedom here in the united
states we got tv freedom your tv your
choice okay that's what i'm saying if
they don't want it on their tv
then don't [ __ ] play it but but the
act of them saying right now oh well
they've got a same-sex couple and it's a
british
show it's a british show but it airs
here in the u.s then don't go to that
channel the reason why it airs on the
network it's because it's really [ __ ]
popular because it's really [ __ ] cute
right if anyone out there has kids they
know our grandkids knows that this
[ __ ] show these kids love this
[ __ ] show and it's
if you think that this show is bad what
the i watched looney tunes when i was a
[ __ ] kid and i'm gonna point this out
because i think this is important listen
to what she says and so parents need to
you know make the choice and they need
but they need to be informed
yeah i i just want to be blunt about it
if there may be some viewers that watch
and say
is this being homophobic
yes yes you're about to be homophobic
when you say when you say i want to be
blunt about it a lot of you yeah yeah
yeah
like look dude you're about to be
homophobic i'm i'm not a racist but
right like if anyone's going to come in
and say
look uh some people might say that this
is transphobic homophobic racist ageist
ableist like if yeah that's what it
introduce
something when you have this like thing
that precedes what you have where you're
like look some people might say this is
this
but and you're like dude you already by
the fact of you saying that you've
already taken away the ability to claim
that it's not that because you're now
using this as an excuse to be like well
look i'm not saying this it's other
people okay and if you're offended
that's on you right well which i mean
you have the right to be offended i also
have the right to know that you're about
to serve us up you're giving us the
warning hey i'm a i'm about to be a
homophobe yeah that's what they should
just do is just have like just flash in
you're like warning warnings
we're about to serve you the homophobic
argument here yeah
and they're like make sure to tivo this
right and listen to this this is that's
incredible
but really what we're looking at or
rather what um
mom speaking out about this is looking
at is is it too young is it too soon to
introduce that am i analyzing that
correctly oh too young to introduce what
so you're telling me that a child
yeah of a same-sex couple
should not acknowledge or learn about
what their parents are in the
relationship and how they fit within the
world at any point like they
these people
these people right now on the show are
going to say no it's inappropriate
people kids who are in uh or the the
child or children of a same-sex couple
guys it's too much for them to handle
they don't know how they they cannot
compute these things well here's the
thing is that what these people these
[ __ ] christian nationalists these
[ __ ]
nazis are scared of what they're
terrified of is that the younger
generation sees that that someone has
two bombs on on a cartoon which happens
in real life too yeah their children
have two moms two dads it happens some
have one mom some have one dad
it just and some have a mommy and a
daddy right that's what happens in
reality here kids
and what what they're what they're
terrified of
is that not that it's inappropriate it's
that that they won't be able to teach
their children bigotry that's what
they're scared of they're scared that
they won't be able to teach their
children to hate these people if peppa
pig shows them that it's yeah it's it's
no big deal right it's really nice and
god forbid that these shows which again
are popular in the us and you know
any you know what any show for that
matter that decides to discuss this do i
yeah no i don't watch it have you
uh i try to remember maybe if
it's cute as [ __ ] man yeah no i've seen
i've seen clips i'm just trying to
remember like if i was ever babysitting
you know in the past and watched it from
like a friend's kit or something it's
been on for a long time yeah like
millions of episodes so i mean like when
they sit down they can watch it for
years and not right right right you know
i'm sure i've passed kids with an ipad
in this in a in a restaurant too
watching peppa pig like on on the ipad
but i will say this like
not only just this show but the fact
that shows bring up you know
stories that are not just about a white
cis dude
it's a talking pig they're talking no no
i know i know but what i'm saying is
like you would you would almost think
like hey this company this network who
makes this show hey says hey look our
demographic our viewers are like our
actual viewer base and the people who
just are representative in the world oh
[ __ ]
they actually aren't just all white
straight people they're a person of
color they come from a different country
they have a different culture religion
they are in a different you know it's a
man and a man or woman a woman or you
know it's a non-binary person with
another non-bearing person or something
else right
like
it's not you're not grooming you're not
using this to create these things you're
not using the show to groom these people
these people exist and they were
represented yeah and they're represented
through the characters in the show right
so that when other people in society go
hey look
my family is different than their family
and now i can see a show where i can go
oh my god that relates because i can
tell you right now children are very
smart they are very smarter than these
two [ __ ] bonuses oh yeah 100
they are able to pick them on things
that that most people don't there's no
filter and the under like the ability to
understand complex situations is
actually
it exists right that is something that
they get they can understand something
also as simple as this person loves this
person right and they are your parents
you need to know and it's really no more
complex that's as far as your business
needs to go exactly but if you see that
if you see on here it says woke culture
because you know they've been on this
cancer culture for for [ __ ] years now
and the reason why they've been on this
tirade about cancer culture is because
they actually want to cancel things and
again it's all projection the imminent
thing the potato they're going to cancel
themselves out of existence because
here's the thing they're going to go
down a checklist and say we can't have
this we can't have that we can't have
that we can't have that and by the end
of the time they're confined within a
box that's like well you
you can't ever go there and you can't
ever say that you can't even do that
because they were the ones who were like
we are triggered
we are triggered by those things that
you
find
uh
uh to be a part of your lives which is
the woe culture right right woke oh
they're woke but listen it gets better
it gets better because we got to get the
bone in the week so let's let's let's
continue
yeah and and parents need to know what
their kids are watching you know in the
old days you watched a cartoon there was
really nothing to discuss after it was
all kind of
non-political no agenda
you know just just funny things to laugh
at uh and you didn't really have to sit
down with your toddler afterwards or
your five-year-old and have a discussion
about what they just watched and so you
know if parents aren't ready to have
these conversations and this this here
is the image that they're that they're
terrified of
look at that they're sitting down and
they're eating pasta oh my gosh why are
we so triggered oh my god pigs shouldn't
eat pasta god damn it they [ __ ] got
him a talking pig shouldn't eat pasta in
the kitchen and dress up apparently i've
never seen a pig with glasses but maybe
there are some also also which i'm sure
you're about to bring up in a moment
about like looney tunes and things like
that but like there are cartoons dude i
watched [ __ ] ren and stimpy as a kid
right that [ __ ] was
that was not appropriate for a kid man
evis and butthead he was a butt dude i'm
not at all dude these were jokes holiday
on it tp for my bungalow
when they zoom in it is very graphic
right like they're like zoomed in on
like an eye that was like [ __ ] busted
and [ __ ] like that is not well i mean do
you remember the violence on on looney
tunes like all out violence do you
remember the racism well yeah well
do i and then the other thing too is
bugs bunny if you remember to get away
from elmer fudd would dress up and drag
to confuse elmer fudd because elmer fudd
apparently is a manga republican and he
would be confused do you also remember
you know pepper pew oh yeah they're
really
a little aggressive you know a little
rapey yeah
but here here they're scared of this
imagery here that comes out of britain
yeah as they say let's let's continue
with their children then they need to
not not let them view these types of
cartoons and yeah
here is that parents need to be aware
because they're just not they've they've
watched peppa pig i think it's been
running for 20 years uh they've watched
it forever and they don't know this
stuff is being introduced so it's
important that news media outlets cover
it and that people speak out just so
people are aware
they may choose to let their children
watch it and have the conversation or
they may not but it's their right to do
so wait wait yeah again
you're telling me you're telling me that
a show is using its program to introduce
a topic that maybe should be discussed
at some point right hmm
maybe maybe you ran right into the point
there dummy let's let's continue he gets
he gets worse here watch this just a
snippet there um again it's two two moms
in the home no no it's two pigs
that's why people didn't drop anvils on
on other people's heads off a cliff
after they watch the road runner and
wiley coyote because it's a [ __ ]
cartoon
oh jesus um
and many are asking is it too early i'm
just curious another night i've said you
saw only you dumb fascists are asking um
obviously it may be in sprinkled into
other shows or other children's books as
we've covered on these broadcasts before
um
is there an is there an age appropriate
time for something like this these
cartoons obviously are are geared for
very young children can you imagine i'm
gonna stop there can you imagine if if
if these people were walking out in
public and they see they see two people
with a young child
and they just they're like oh there's
two there's two women with one job and
they're eating spaghetti yeah at this
restaurant and they just freak the [ __ ]
out i mean they're freaking out and like
hey wait a second i'm i'm this child's
mom and she's
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you i mean
really honestly that's what they're
doing here freak out
the woman so i just did a quick search
really quick the moms of liberty and i'm
reading about their about page was that
tiffany or was that tina i think it
might have been
tina tina okay so you know dina
deskovich right she has a long record of
fighting for students and parental
rights in florida at a national level
she was elected blah blah blah she was
elected again for this other thing while
on the board she was a member of the
florida coalition of school board
members and serves the organization
president of 2018. tina currently serves
on several nonprofits that's [ __ ]
terrifying in her community that are
aimed at helping children
nope not she and her husband derek
sounds like a dick have five children i
feel sorry for them if your mother is
this person who is that much of a
controlling uh fascist she's passionate
about american is dedicated to
protecting liberty and freedom
freedom
freedom now for the nature of all
children
so here's the thing
i don't see anywhere in this bio
that she's a clinical uh psychologist or
therapist
or uh um a pediatrician or anyone that
she's just a dumb manga republican is
that right you're saying like
i'm saying that she's not a trained
professional that would know the answer
to so at what point are we able to
introduce these things into a child's
life right that person on your own
personal level as a mother you can do
whatever you want right that's your
liberty
liberty and your freedom and your own
your own family
you have you like joe biden says you
have the right to be a [ __ ] idiot
yeah you have the right to be an idiot
then it's america speaking of rights to
be idiots i bet tina and this lady would
get along then we'll go to bonehead of
the week once yeah it's fun to be here
it's fun to have a big family who who
here has
who
who here has at least eight there's
eight kids in your family
[ __ ] my kids
there's some breeders here all
right i'm not [ __ ] you let's back it
up let's rewatch before we go to
bonehead because this is a real [ __ ]
bone in here watch this
yeah right there's a
there's some breeders here all right
oh my god tina and her would get along
really well oh that
is
bonus
wow jesus christ man breeders that type
of language is the same as like i need a
ve an earthen vessel i need a i need a
producer of of
bodies
there is there's a great um part of
liberty in this country and joe biden
said it so well you do
you do have the freedom and the right to
be really [ __ ] stupid and that
that is just
not the stupidest [ __ ] thing i've
ever heard everyone stick around we got
boneheads just like her for bone end of
the week when we come back right after
this break stick around don't go
anywhere bone of the week when we come
back
we'll be right back
mark
60 seconds this is the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capitol have you been left out in
the cold after stealing nancy pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi i'm paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket i've got
you covered pardon blanket specifically
works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on january 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of congress who also helped with the
attempted coup pardon blanket will
protect you too pardon blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the usa don't delay and
get your part in blanket today for just
99.99
actual parting's not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the tony
michaels podcast
welcome back to the show
friday so we're in the second hour
we're going to bone end of the week
that clip with the lady with the
breeders talk
what in the actual [ __ ] is going on
oh my god it just gets dumber and dumber
and dumber and they get dumber and
dumber and dumber and i think i really
they gave that's the point here they are
dumb it is really [ __ ]
we're we're all the way down the stupid
slide here like we're almost there to
just the dumb ones left in the manga
republicans you think you've seen it all
and then the mega republicans and other
people on the right come out and say
hold my beer so you have you have uh
pennsylvania's mussolini masteriano
saying no exceptions
because i know a person who is a
product of rape
yeah and then you have this lady who's
like yeah where's my breeders at like oh
my god yeah eight children that's a lot
of kids to have and that is a lot of
kids to support which is a very
difficult thing financially to do but
also it's like yeah well we got to be
breeding these kids
where i come from in the midwest
i know a lot of families that had a lot
of children i mean 8 10 12. i know i
know some families that we were close to
in my hometown that had 10 8 to 10 to
twelve children that is another kid
there were several families but i don't
ever remember i don't ever remember
thinking that the mom was a breeder like
we i don't i don't remember that kind of
talk i mean they were like
boy she knows how to she knows how to
cook because she's got to make a lot of
[ __ ] a lot of food yeah well i mean
that type of
that type of language and that type of
like labeling of someone's like yeah
well guess what you're not a person
you're just a breeder right you're just
gonna ship and ship out you know i mean
isn't that their goal here i mean
with the no exception talk with this
breeder talk with this you don't know
you don't know what's good for your kids
even no peppa pig you can watch it and
know that it's not bad for your children
i mean it's definitely not anywhere near
as damaging as what looney tunes was to
me that's why i'm so [ __ ] up
probably because i'm [ __ ] looney
tunes i'm dead serious animaniacs looney
tunes
this is why i'm damaged yeah you're
damaging your damage good but we
appreciate you right but no i didn't
have peppa peppa pig i didn't have that
right i mean i grew up on like peewee's
playhouse so that really [ __ ] me up
yeah
oh that's what's wrong with you yeah
yeah
i see i see well let's do this let's go
to bone end of the week it's friday
let's start the music
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to this edition of bonehead of
the week okay we got a lot of boneheads
this week but every week we have a lot
of bonuses well you know with these
republicans there's no need to uh think
that we're gonna have a low inventory of
[ __ ] morons um but this week
one really worked its way out front he
really and i mean so much so that they
even had like a kind of a small parade
for him oh um to a courtroom it was
pretty cool i don't want to give it away
but yeah yeah um but this week our
boneheads
um again we had three of them senator
marco rubio which again he's always a
bonehead always and then we have mayman
oz
dr oz
is a [ __ ] idiot he of course he's a
moment and then
scabby steve bannon who has been steve
bannon charged with six
six
crimes in the state of new york uh
including money laundering
and deep fraud scheming to defraud
um is is part of those six counts and he
was
he was shown yesterday to be
surrendering to the prosecutors and the
best part is normally when someone
surrenders like that you know like they
don't perp walk them no yeah normally
but they were like no we're gonna burp
walk your ass dummy and they did the
burp walk and it was ma i mean
everyone's waiting like it was a
premiere of a hollywood film you've got
the velvet row people chanting and
sharing obviously because they hate them
but the crowd there you know inside and
outside of the building oh they were
dedicated fans dedicated fans that hate
his [ __ ] guts oh this this that lady
outside like i said uh she deserves
flowers yeah yeah no she is the modern
day saint oh she is the beautiful
beautiful and i think i found her on
twitter so i'm gonna try to see if we
can
get her to uh come here so we can thank
her i'd like to thank her personally is
what i'd like to do for her i'd also
like to know democracy you know which uh
which
kind of arrangements or events she's
going to next
uh just to give her some moral support
yeah well i mean i know i know um
it sounds like she does events all the
time she's constantly
fighting for our democracy which is good
because
we need people like her in the fight
especially people who are who are spicy
and salty because we need to
we need to really hammer these son of a
[ __ ] as we see with these boneheads
this week yeah why did center marco
rubio make it on our list
that is a what was the clip that i sent
you this week i have no idea you know
rubio said some dumb [ __ ] this week so
what was it
there was something because this was an
er i feel like this was an early week
it is early it was earlier on in the
week it is where uh he talked about um
storage oh storage
yeah yeah when he was on fox and friends
yeah so yeah yeah so that was the uh
that was him do you have the clip or do
you need it he's also well he's also i'm
pulling up clips here but he's also um
if you want to find that storage clip he
saw he was also very
upset about the leaks so if you'll find
the storage clip i'll play the clip here
of the uh the leaks here because he was
on fox and friends and he thinks it's
egregious yeah you know forget the
crimes forget the crimes committed well
they don't care about the when you steal
top secret documents
what he's upset about is people are
leaking that these that this former
president committed crimes it's
ridiculous that you would leak that he
committed crime
how dare they how are they how we should
be outraged about it how dare they
inform the public about the extent you
know not the details specifically but
how dare all right these these law
enforcement agencies say like hey press
you might want to know that donald trump
had these nuclear documents at his kind
of disposal in his private residence at
mar-a-lago not under lock and key in
some facility that was supposed like a
skiff or somewhere it's supposed to be
or you know protected by the government
it was just in a desk
crazy
listen let's listen a little marco here
try to justify how the leaks are worse
than the crimes committed no you can
understand why uh you know when we first
heard about this stuff when we heard
well maybe it's things like a note from
kim jong-un to
uh president trump that he wanted juicy
trying really hard here by the way yeah
if true this washington post report
highly classified documents at
mar-a-lago
uh that only a cabinet level officer or
hire could even look at that doesn't
seem like the kind of thing you should
have
in your post-presidential
desk drawer
steve ducey really try i mean he's
trying so hard he's like i don't i don't
wanna i don't want to be a total [ __ ]
to you right now
but i'm just gonna ask you the question
that i think is a rational you know
reasonable question that most people
wonder which is why did he have these
documents that are only available to be
seen and viewed and held by people of
cabinet level status or other people
like them that have been given access
right like why did they have them i mean
brian kilmeat over here is like [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] oh god do you see enough of
the half-assed journalism enough of the
half-assed because this is not what week
two or so that that ducey has now been
asking just he's not even complicated
questions he's just like why did he have
these documents and it seems like he has
been just brutal like you know because
he has a journey
he's asked marco rubio and i mean so
he's not he's not out of line here he
really he's not doing his job it's the
bare minimum it's the bare minimum
question
to be like yeah he's just edging up to
bare minimum he's like look i mean why
did he have the stuff bare minimum
should be why are you still supporting a
person who is alleged to have top stole
our government stopped top secret
documents and stored them in a place
where anyone could get to them and
you're on the senate intelligence
committee tell us senator you being on
that how are you still supporting this
person that should be the [ __ ]
question but but let's see what marco's
answer is here about the crimes that are
committed let's listen
well let's break this down first of all
again we really don't know because let's
go back no we do know yeah
we don't understand all of this
information is coming from one side and
one place yep yep it sure is it sure is
because they had to go take the top
secret documents that he stole that's
why it's coming from one place called
the uh department of what the hell is
that department called
justice yeah justice is that how you say
it okay that's that's how the
the europeans say it oh okay
department of justice
sources with knowledge of the
investigation well who are the sources
with knowledge of the investigation the
people who are investigating this
department yes leaking to the media
not only that oh my god
who are the sources
donald trump is the [ __ ] source he's
the reason why we know this doj says hey
look we've got this stuff we don't want
to release it can you just comply and he
goes no no no no i'm not going to comply
and then it was his back and forth
20-month thing and then now donald trump
you know from august 8th from the from
the [ __ ] get-go he goes
this is this is an obstruction of my own
uh my own liberties and freedom and
privacy like they're they're they're
coming they're coming into my home and
and they're rating and they're going
through melania's stuff and they're
going through my my son uh
uh baron you know all of this stuff
where it's like
if you had just done
what you're supposed to do which is
don't steal the documents right don't
then you wouldn't have the fbi come into
your home and if you didn't lie and
steal and hide them over a 20-month
period they wouldn't have had to come in
with a search warrant they wouldn't be
investigating for obstruction right but
marco rubio thinks it's not about
obstruction
it's a storage issue let's listen this
is really at its core a storage argument
that they're making right they're
arguing there are documents there
they don't deny that he should have
access to those documents but they deny
that they were not properly stored
that's not at all what they're saying
not even close even the department of
justice in their appeal this morning is
saying look these aren't his documents
it's not his [ __ ] it's our [ __ ] it's the
government [ __ ] they're not his he is
not uh documents that he could have any
no he is not supposed to have these
documents right that at the heart of it
is the actual issue here is that he
stole
our [ __ ]
and and let's remember that when you're
the president you are a servant of the
people you serve
the people in the office united states
exactly and then when you leave that
office another person comes in and they
serve the people and when you leave you
don't serve the people you do you know
you would hope that you would try to do
some good but donald trump is [ __ ]
just blowing this [ __ ] to pieces and
burning it down the guy left with
documents
denied he had the documents was shown
that he had the documents admitted that
he had the documents then he said i
declassified the documents meanwhile
everyone's like it doesn't work that way
you cannot declassify these a former
president cannot just retrospectively
say hey or retroactively just like you
know what i thought
i thought about it yeah i thought i
considered it i thought when i was
president so i'm gonna i'm gonna post it
on truth social and now it is the law of
the land it's really stupid and marco
rubio's really [ __ ] stupid and let me
tell you if you think marco rubio is a
bonehead and you live in florida there's
something you can do about even if you
don't live in florida there's something
you do about a val dimmings man she is
coming up
in this race she's going to kick his ass
in florida i think she may help pull
charlie chris and charlie chris may help
pull her over the line in florida have
some [ __ ] common sense brought back
to florida instead of this fascist state
blueprint that they have going on there
speaking of elections and states
dr oz is trying trying his best
to look like he's from pennsylvania um
he's doing he's been unsuccessful at
every
every point
you know down the road well i mean you
know
he
he's like a fish out of water here
because not only not only does is he not
from pennsylvania it doesn't even appear
that he's from pennsylvania and really
honestly um he's lying his ass off this
morning on fox news now i don't know
exactly why he's on our bone ed but he
was on fox news this morning here's a
clip from him talking about how just
lying to pennsylvanians we put him on we
put him on this week's bonehead for the
physical comment
the physical yeah yeah
that was the that was the like oh the 15
minutes uh for a physical
oh yeah yeah yeah get that clip for me
because that's an old that's an old clip
from a while back but this is a brand
new fresh clip brought to you by the
tony michaels podcast this one's fresh
right off the presses
from from new jersey straight to
pennsylvania yeah let's listen as the
brace tightens dramatically which it is
doing no no it's not no it's not it's
not tightening no that's not true you're
a [ __ ] idiot it's not tightening it's
getting closer to election time if
that's what you mean but it's not
tightening people begin to understand
how radical he really is
okay that the guy wears a hoodie all
right all right
also the guy
the guy is he's like what six eight
right some [ __ ] like that which if i was
that tall and i was that big
i would probably have a hard time
finding a suit you know especially in
that quantity to be like look i'll wear
the suit when you guys elect me yeah but
do you think people in pennsylvania that
are going to be
are you going to think are you going to
convince them that wearing a hoodie a
carhartt hoodie is radical are you
[ __ ] [ __ ] me you're talking about the
one of the heartbeat of [ __ ] usa
right
this is ridiculous
that the rust belt that think that these
people are going to accuse john
fetterman of being a radical because he
wears a hoodie
like god forbid you wear the brand for
the clothing that we wear and our
uniforms right on our blue collar jobs
[ __ ] you man how can i hear you you know
you radical listen this is it gets
better the independent vote is shifting
in my direction no it's not intellectual
no optimism
she's even like hmm i don't believe you
i don't i don't know what to say here um
what you're talking about that is not
the truth let's listen confident that we
will prevail in november we got the
right ideas at the right time and he's
unable to articulate a defense for what
he likes to do which is to tweet out
ideas that sound good to him at the time
but make no sense and hurt the
commonwealth of pennsylvania and isn't
this the guy who tweeted the video about
him going to a grocery store and getting
crew today yeah yeah i'm not the same
guy yeah i i think it's the same guy but
maybe i'm wrong maybe
maybe maybe that's not the thing what i
will say is dr oz is clearly butt hurt
because every time that oz does
something
fetterman and his team
post something that ends up going viral
and it's pretty funny right when he
talked about being from south florida
they released a video of just like
zooming in on google maps and then going
below south florida like oh look this is
where he's from new jersey so you mean
south south philly yeah south philly
yeah
yeah
yeah uh you said south florida oh that
says oh you said south florida i'm
mixing up people in pennsylvania are now
going to be anti-gay oh no
look here i am you put your heart hoodie
on [ __ ] this is you're a radical gay
this is what happens when i get little
sleep and we're talking about republican
bone heads you know i know well i
apologize i meant new jersey what
happened what's happening is you're
confusing republicans in florida for
republicans in pennsylvania because they
i mean they share the same fascist
ideology right well here is uh dr oz now
i'm not sure when this was what year um
this is some sort of speech that he's
giving to the national governors
association i'm not sure why he's
demeaning people who don't have health
insurance but he's doing it let's listen
now when you go home today what should
you do
i think you ought to think about
15-minute physicals your local hospitals
will fund these they're incredibly
inexpensive to run you can screen
thousands of people for almost nothing
and you allow a conversation to take
place in more of a festival-like setting
it's not scary and i mentioned earlier
that almost everybody who comes to our
our 50-minute physicals has a job but a
lot don't have insurance give them a way
of crawling back out of the abyss
of darkness of fear over not having the
health they need and give them an
opportunity because they don't have the
right to health but they have the right
to access a chance to get that health
so is he saying in this clip because i
take that what he's saying is is that
people who don't have insurance don't
have a right to health so what he said
he literally they don't have a right to
health but they do have a right to
access
hmm it's very strange it's very strange
his take on don't also like a
festival-like setting you're just gonna
go like okay for anyone who has done a
physical there are a lot of things that
go in right you're getting your weight
your temperature taken they're
inspecting other parts of your body it
doesn't seem that's really like a
15-minute thing to do like a festive
thing and not only that but like he what
he's proposing is like he's setting up a
bunch of goddamn tents in a in a in a
parking lot
like it's
like it's some sort of festival-like
setting oh that's what he means so like
people are gonna like come there and
yeah they just walk and walk out but
what he's like when that's a festival
though gabe you go to all these like
these little these little trailers and
these little tents where they have
really shitty food like it's great they
[ __ ] taste awesome it's all [ __ ]
fried it's all greasy i mean you can't
even i mean by time you get done eating
it the napkin is just soaked and nasty
but it's it they're it's fantastic
funnel cake corn dogs lemonade not
turkey legs i keep going what else you
got right i mean cotton candy i mean you
name it
a caramel corn yeah
a kettle corn i mean you need to just
keep going
all great stuff by the way all festive
stuff but is that what he's saying is
we're supposed to the way that i take
this right now is that he's talking
about setting up tents in some open area
like some field or some parking lot if
he's talking about being near a hospital
right in terms of proximity to a
hospital and what they have available in
resources but the idea of what he's
talking about reminds me of of like a
fire festival right like it would be the
fire festival of physicals is the way
that i take it him describe it do you
know what the fire fest i've never been
but i i've no there's no way that you
could only well there's only only
happened once it was a it was a one and
done it was a failure you know i could i
could have went there oh you hadn't you
had all those no i did dollars i did not
but but there it is a possibility that i
could have sure yeah you could have gone
there and you could have gotten a simple
sandwich with uh a tomato lettuce on on
uh on bread on one talking about the one
you're talking about the one that the
john rule one yeah the john rule and the
other guy that's right
is it
[Music]
um i know what you're talking about yeah
yeah is it netflix down here yeah billy
mcfarlane yeah
yeah yeah i could have one i mean i
didn't go yeah i i wouldn't go to
anything like but that's what that but
the way that he describes in a
festival-like setting that could be it
which is it sounds like an absolute [ __ ]
show based on you know what is involved
with the physical and how many people
are available not only that the biggest
thing when it comes to a physical is
your goddamn privacy to be in a room
with a closed door so no one else can
see what you're doing it's a very
vulnerable thing to do because you take
off your clothes oh hey let me check
this let me check that i'm in a you know
whatever the doctor's going to check you
in certain places to make sure you're
healthy everywhere right the idea that
you go in and out with the hospital gown
naked in a tent or even without a gown
like he's like oh it's very inspect
inexpensive it's quick
potties at this uh 15 minute physical
special thing at this festival
i don't know who knows like like a whole
bank of them you know what i'm talking
about yeah no i mean you know when you
when you eat the funnel cake and you eat
them right right and they just sometimes
you got up through right well you got
the beer tent and the beer garden
everything else i mean sometimes you got
it you gotta go you guys it sounds it
sounds like an absolute [ __ ] show
i would say it's the fire festival
of physicals
well dr oz is definitely a [ __ ]
bonehead this week so thanks dr oz for
making the cut here um let's go to our
dm speaking of [ __ ] shows uh peter
navarro your buddy peter
mentioned my whole honorable mention
this week oh my god this [ __ ] guy
i cannot believe this peter navarro
i guess he filled in for for banning
yesterday because bannon was um i don't
know what was wrong was he sick what
what what what happened why couldn't
steve bannon i think
he was a little bit busy he was
traveling oh yeah okay he was on the
road walking yeah he was walking uh busy
walking couldn't couldn't be on the air
but i'm glad that peter navarro was so
nice so you're saying you can't go
podcast when you're handcuffed is that
what you're saying no you can't podcast
from jail either so i am super excited
that donald trump and all the other mag
republicans are going to lose their
megaphone that is steve bannon well you
know peter navarro talks about that in
this clip that's why he is our
dishonesty he's next on the list by the
way he is he is definitely not going to
be podcasting uh for steve bannon very
long yeah they're going to need a new
guest co-host i i like the idea of them
just handing off to the next person to
the next person and each person is
getting arraigned or indicted or
arrested and put in jail and they're
like they just have a
a long list of people that are right all
fraud right marjorie taylor green's
gonna be a a coho a guest coast that's
going to be a rain i mean this is all
going to happen you know the real crime
here is where in the [ __ ] is he placing
himself on this green screen why would
you choose this picture
why is this is this not the cdc i have
no idea what is this i'm not certain but
i don't feel like it's really [ __ ]
weird why wouldn't i mean if you were
gonna go anywhere you wanted to go you
think you'd go somewhere other than
this business park or whatever the hell
this is yeah what the [ __ ] let's listen
let's listen to uh bonehead navarro here
about it i'm here today talking with you
yeah because stephen k bannon is a
powerful political voice
right now in america no no no was he was
he was he's not he he's arrested he's
gonna go to jail he was you can't
you can't you podcast from jail but you
know let's let's finish
and they want to shut him up yep that's
what this
is all
about yeah it's about he committed
crimes and he's gonna go to jail for
those crimes
even even even if the the former guy
the former guy pardoned him from federal
crimes right he's not going to get away
with the state crime yeah and they
forgot where the hell this is at did you
figure out no i don't know if it's cdc i
thought because he's weird
it's almost like he's like you know what
um just pick out the local business part
give me a break well i don't it's
definitely not in dc i don't think so i
mean like look at this there's like a
mountain ridge in the background if
anyone in the chat knows this
isn't because i've seen him use it when
he's talked about uh fauci before and i
don't know if those two are connected so
if he's like oh this is a building
there's a medical facility of some sort
uh i don't know it is really weird it's
really the high crime here
is that the background that he's using
maybe he didn't know what he was you
know he's standing from a green screen
maybe
there's two types of backgrounds he does
one
is uh he's got the well he's got a day
and night version of the
what looks like uh
um
it looks like i think it's it's a dc
background i think it's a dc background
um somebody on one somebody said
where's the chat the chat no he said
woohon lab in china oh jesus christ let
me see oh man that kid please tell me
that's not he didn't place himself in
china this one let me see why you're
looking at that yes this is where this
is
robert from youtube is correct uh you
win you win the the background award
boom
boom robert this is the yeah right on it
china
i told you
i told you there's a reason why he
brings it up when he talks about what it
is
okay well let's let's listen to this
look because this this almost gets
better this almost gets better i don't
know if it can get better but let's
listen in a blue stronghold
using
law fair
to try to what what is
what is law fair i'm i'm not is he
saying is he is did he mean warfare and
then he's like use the law i think
that's what he's saying is i don't know
i think you the [ __ ] out of someone and
tell you yeah i think uh i think
webster's uh dictionary needs to jump in
and give a comment here right what law
fair right or maybe maybe like this
i'm sure it's a word it's a [ __ ] there's
a word i wonder i wonder if it's like
you know like dr oz talked about a
festival-like setting this one is like a
law fair so you're there at a fair and
you're like hey look this law school and
that law firm and this and that you know
and this right-wing nut job that's
spreading conspiracy theories is the
lawyer that works for donald trump named
alina habba who knows
who knows tony the best part about the
other crime here is this little thing
right here it says dr peter navarro okay
let's continue
the silence
the man the man k bannon
who
has through the force
of his intellect
taken this show are the number one
podcast
and show
in politics in the world
okay number one that is that's such an
atrocity why don't you folks do me a
favor and spread around
this show the tony michaels podcast and
bone of the week so we can be number one
so these [ __ ] idiots don't get to say
this kind of [ __ ] because really
honestly that
maybe that's the highest crime here with
what navarre is saying but you know i i
looked up law fair by the way yeah yeah
okay what law fair is the use of legal
systems and institutions to damage or
de-legitimate de-legitimize an opponent
or to deter individuals usage of their
legal rights so he's saying lawfare on
democracy is because he's projecting
here he's like ah they're using law fair
to shut him up no
he talks too much
right and he crimes too much right two
things
kind of different some of them are the
same
but just because you talk too much
doesn't mean they can't you know hold
you accountable for criming too much
there's a thing they can do peter
navarro
so if that's what you consider lafayette
so peter navarro is our dishonorable
mention this week for bone end of the
week
gabe who ended up being our alpha cuck
this week who got caught oh
boy donald j
trump
as the alpha guk
weeks in a row yeah he was on it last
week
and he came back and he was like
last week he got an alpha cuck last week
oh my god what was he alpha i don't even
remember he got alpha cut by the doj oh
yeah yeah now i remember he is because
he was like hey this is [ __ ] and the
doj was like man you don't want to keep
doing this we're just going to keep
embarrassing you because you broke the
[ __ ] law and they embarrassed him
this morning again too yeah i don't know
if you don't know if you saw this but
they embarrassed the [ __ ] out of him
um when they when well they filed they
filed the doj filed the response right
last night it was
yes yeah doj filed a response and
basically said he doesn't own these
documents and really honestly the judge
is getting cuck there too yeah yeah um
the judge is getting really cocked there
too but but um let's see why donald
trump was alphacock this week whoa hey
there we are this is
this is reception dude this is like
i am not wearing the same shirt i just
don't know a lot of black shirts i
promise okay all right it's i'm not
pulling a steve bannon i was just gonna
say that sounds like steve bannon one
shirt and i launder my shirts not the
the money okay okay so
here is uh the video of
rick wilson absolutely turning down a
trump into a cuck and we we went over
this yesterday but let's let's play it
again can't wait i would imagine that
rick is gonna challenge him here um but
let's let's see what says you rick to
just give donald trump a message since
you threatened to sue the lincoln
project this morning
go for it
go for it [ __ ]
come at me
i can't wait we're we're delighted by
the thought that you would try to sue us
donald do it
do it
i double dog dare you you know when we
put up the billboards in times square of
jared and ivanka during the coveted
crisis at the end of the 2020 campaign
we received this letter from mark castle
it's donald trump's attorney and it was
this complete you know blustering [ __ ]
show oh we're all sort of sue you we
read it in the bane voice right
you're not gonna sue anybody donald
you're not going to do [ __ ] you're not
going to do a goddamn thing you are weak
you are impotent you are flabby you are
sitting there in the bridal suite at
mar-a-lago or in the bridal suite at
bedminster grinding your gears wondering
why
the lincoln project no matter how many
times you tried to kill us keeps coming
at you you know oh my god i i it just it
um what sweet words from from rick
wilson i think
the funniest there uh
a couple funny moments there but i think
my favorite is i double dog dare you
which
i don't hear very often these days right
uh it was a very popular thing to say as
a kid
right and i you know i probably kids say
it even now but when you're when you're
challenging someone as an adult
nobody says
i double dog dare you and it just adds
to the whole like the hilarious nature
of this whole thing which is donald
trump thinks he can sue whoever he wants
because they made something again
practicing the freedom of speech the
first amendment
and what they're saying is not untrue it
is completely 100 true he grifted people
from their money took it and then took
advantage of a group and hopefully now
that they're exposing donald trump for
the fraud and the criminal that he is
maybe they will turn around and say [ __ ]
we should not be supporting this guy
because what you're talking about is the
lincoln project ed and i'm we don't have
time to play the ad here but we did post
this full re uh uh
react to
not just not just the ad and rick
wilson's video but we actually we showed
the donald trump um fraud social post
over on our youtube channel so so go
subscribe to the tony michaels podcast
subscribe right now and you can go to uh
our channel and see that portion of the
show yesterday
from how we reacted to not only the
video of rick wilson but also the the
true social post and the ad that lincoln
project that so pissed donald trump off
and really really gotten his snowflake
feelings and and caused rick to make
this video but this also
this type of uh response is
i believe there's a changing
um
uh kind of
attitude
for people on the left or even people in
the center or on the right that are done
with donald trump and the mag
republicans but what i feel like is
happening
is people are fed up right but they're
also seeing the way in which
uh democrats respond which is
hey everyone's entitled to be an idiot
uh they don't you know they don't ever
have uh or they've never suffered from
good manners right they there's this
constant calling out now of mega are a
bunch of fascists their policies are
terrible and detrimental to your
livelihood and well-being they don't
have your uh well-being you know into
consideration it's only for themselves
and and how they can profit
and so now you're seeing people like
[ __ ] this man [ __ ] you and [ __ ]
everything that you're doing right now
because you are a terrible human and you
don't represent me or anyone else that
are supposed to be your constituents and
i think i think now there's a changing
behavior and an attitude where people
are just like [ __ ] it i'm just gonna
call you [ __ ] out for the monster
that you are
and everyone's like yeah this is great
we should do more of this speaking of
calling out monsters
it brings us to
the bone end of the week steve bannon um
because
as you know there is a great video of a
sweet sweet lady and again i'm i want to
send her flowers so if i can figure out
where to send him to i'm going to send
her some flowers here
because she did this country a great
service yesterday when she was standing
there as steve bannon entered the the
courthouse to surrender himself to
prosecutors for the six crimes they
charged him with
the best part is is he tried to play
victim but she wasn't having any of it
let's let's watch let's watch this
beautiful beautiful i told you it's like
a hollywood premiere look at this it is
it's great
[Music]
i don't know if you count this game but
there's a lady who is being very loud in
the background
and as steve bannon starts to speak
she's like ah [ __ ] and she gets
closer and closer and closer to drown
him out and the end the ending on this
on this clip is just people need to
bring whistles you know because this
reminds me this reminds me of when steve
bannon tried to spread some [ __ ]
after one of his court appearances and
there was the guy that's in dc and there
was the guy with the whistle which i
think might have been the same guy that
blew the whistle at margaret taylor
green and mac gates last year and made
them run away and back down after they
said we will not back down boom blow the
whistle
crazy powers this whistle has against
fascists it's amazing
well you know
woody guthrie used to have a guitar and
he and on the guitar it said this
machine kills fascists and maybe
a whistle with this machine kills
fascists on it maybe maybe we should put
that somewhere
i don't know what i'm just saying but
let's let's watch how she
she kills fascist here and fascism as
he's trying to spew it out his pie hole
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
stop hurting america you greasy stupid
grifter
you greasy two-bit grifter oh
she is after my heart gabe she's after
my heart i have this image in my mind of
people that are in the rotating door and
they're catching like moments of it
they're like
like oh you mean like so they can't hear
all they just right so they might you
know they might catch like something
that's faint or whatever but as they're
going through like parts are be like you
two you're like you crazy with grifter
like you know it's like
oh my god well what a great piece of
video but gabe there was a piece of
footage of steve bannon the bone end of
the week
that was even better i didn't know it
could get even better because yesterday
we watched that piece of footage on the
show but this other piece of footage
hadn't happened yet and i was like i
don't think this day can get any better
but it totally did it got so much better
with this little piece of footage
and it is
it is steve bannon and it appears that
he's being purple let's take a look
for every conservative
this is what happens in the last days of
the dying regime
they will never shut me up and kill me
first
oh when you go to wright case when he
goes to writers there's a very good
chance that they'll shut him up or kill
him at rikers they oh my god they're not
gonna put up with this [ __ ] i have i
have an idea that uh if he were to say
[ __ ] because i don't actually think he
would when he goes through and they're
like all right cool we got to do a
cavity check which i feel i have
an immense amount
of
just uh predicting the immense amount of
like sympathy
for whoever
has to do that check right like
those are cavities you do not want to
search that is like uh
that's like when you you find like a
beached like shark and you're like hey
what the hell did this thing eat and
then it's like a life
random plastic you know some of this
[ __ ] that's what it's gonna be there's
no telling how many things that steve
bannon has keistered and forgotten about
there's no telling how many wearing what
three or four shirts in a jacket like we
don't know what's underneath those other
black shirts well you don't you have no
idea you have no idea and he is a greasy
grifter i want to point out though and
this is a great shot of this though this
is going to be the iconic shot right
here on the screen of steve bannon oh
yeah in a pair of handcuffs here as
these as these marshals are taking him
into the courtroom and but i want to
point out something
they did all this on purpose oh yeah
they've got the barricade there they got
the [ __ ] media barricade they're like
no we're gonna walk him right down this
hallway everyone's set up we're gonna do
the burp walk we're gonna let america
see this guy lose his [ __ ] mind and
we're gonna create a piece of content
that's gonna live in history forever and
ever and ever and i just my heart hopes
my heart hopes gabe that there is a
moment
when donald trump is finally held
accountable that they do the exact same
thing to him that they did yeah yeah
yeah yeah
that's my i can't wait i mean like this
right here
right now because right now what's
happening uh they have the venice film
festival that that i think
might still be happening or just ended
i'm getting the same vibes as this the
only difference is they don't have a red
carpet and a backdrop right but they've
got a barricade to be like no no press
and reporters you're on this side and
the people who are premiering in this
film are on this side and
bannon's film is just called uh
fraud [ __ ] i don't know what it's
called right right
treason hunters yeah
yeah trees and hunters um you know
it really
again it warms my heart
that steve bannon is being toaded off to
jail and you know
here's the thing he's being held
accountable for crimes that we know he
committed and the reason why we know it
is because donald trump pardoned him for
these crimes federally so in essence he
had to admit
right to these crimes
but we don't know what the crimes were
right because they were just like look
well
he might have pardoned him of the
charges
of the indictment that they charged him
with right right and i think it was an
exchange of him doing what he does every
day which is to try to overturn this
country to give it back to trump well
the reason i mean steve bannon left the
white house and left the administration
as the advisor after i think it was
after charleston right
it could be yeah i think because it was
that point when steve bannon said ah
okay
my young padawan has learned
because he was like oh there were good
people on both sides you know uh
misunderstanding it's like oh you're
defending these these nazis
you're defending the people that came
through the town
and were like ah
charlottesville sorry i said charleston
uh
but i think at that point was i think
was shortly after steve bannon was like
okay the young boy has grown out to be a
man a racist man
well speaking of padawans and steve
bannon here's one other good clip now
this is from real america's voice it's
the same trader
network and one of our favorites one of
our favorite ears bonanz charlie kirk
whining and crying about steve bannon
listening this is beautiful this is
another piece of beautiful footage so
now the priority is
indicted he's so upset
oh my god he's so upset gabe like i
haven't even started this clip and i'm i
mean tears are coming to minds because
he's so upset he's steve bannon
it's a term we've used quite often here
on this program anarcho
tyranny
anarchy on the streets
tyranny against the political
dissidence anarchy in the streets
tyranny in the sheets is that what is
that where he's getting this from
that's exactly what i thought he was
going to say when he started when he's
whenever he's going to say something in
the streets that i think something in
the house in the sheets right
right we should make it we should make a
shirt it says anarchy in the streets
tyranny in the sheets put it mark it
down mark it down we're gonna make a
t-shirt everyone you heard that we're
gonna we're gonna do a t-shirt design of
anarchy
and tyranny in the sheets let's listen
they will use political force and power
to lock up conservatives but thugs
criminals child predators pedophiles
arsonists murderers
no bail
but if you dare speak out in favor of
donald trump we will raid your home
nope that's not how that works that's
not how that works this is hilarious i
love his
which is funny because i almost use an
exact same line in this new upcoming
what was that which is i say
if you go against or you speak out
against trump and the mega
uh
fascists
then you
are an enemy of the state because that's
the same that's the same language that
trump was using during that pennsylvania
rally where he was like oh
you're an enemy this state you know
obviously saying in a joking manner but
then saying in a serious way joe biden
is the enemy of the state which is like
also are we going to ignore that the guy
is being investigated for espionage like
he's he violated the espionage act
nothing screams enemy of the state more
than [ __ ] treason well i mean they
are treasonous pieces of [ __ ] and uh
let's give our bone end of the week or
treasonous piece of [ __ ] of the week his
dues steve bannon yuan bone end of the
week thanks buddy for being on the bone
of the week let's give him his dude
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
oh scabby steve bonen of the week
boom boom oh my god
sb steve bannon sb scabby bonehead
scabby bonehead steve bannon thanks for
coming to
this segment of bone end of the week uh
make sure every single friday you join
us on the tony michaels podcast and the
mind is touch network for bone end of
the week subscribe to the tony michaels
podcast do not forget because we do a
show every single weekday monday through
friday noon eastern 11 central 9 pacific
on youtube twitter and twitch and we
simulcast to the minus touch facebook
page also don't forget to subscribe here
if you're watching on the midas touch
network subscribe here now because
you're probably watching on a replay on
friday nights as we do that every single
week now
also follow us at tony michael's pod so
you can vote
on bone end of the week on the poll
because you vote you decide we break it
down every single friday in the second
hour of the tony michaels podcast and
don't forget to download every single
episode on apple spotify and google
hey it was a great week for boneheads we
had some great contestants i mean
they're you know democracy and justice
really coming through in the 11th hour
here i know you know but the i'm not
wondering what's going on king the manga
ultra boned king
he came out front it was close but he
came
i mean when it was started there was a
moment where you sent me a screenshot
and you're like oh
boy possible he is a [ __ ] bonehead
though but bannon
he really pulled it out like i knew he
would i knew i knew he would be our
bonehead of the week thank you everyone
for joining us stick around if you're on
the tony michaels podcast we have a few
announcements right after the song stick
around thanks for joining us bonehead of
the week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
my favorite my favorite segment it's
great i love it i mean i like the
shitless roundup the booming of the week
man it just makes my whole week that's
why we do it at the end yeah because
it's like the exclamation point it's
like boom
this is what happened
you're boneheads that's right and your
neck of the woods you know and i and i
you know this was always because we we
kind of cooked this up but you had this
idea that we'd do a weekend thing
and i was like hey that that bone-head
thing that we've been talking about we
should make that kind of like a segment
right and you're like yeah we should let
them vote and that's where this whole
thing came from right right because we
had you know the simple idea because it
was one it was we the show was one day a
week it was one it was wednesday and
then it was like we're [ __ ] we're
doing every day well monday through
friday right and then when we were
talking it was like yeah okay we need
something like we need like a mini like
a mini little episode kind of thing to
like
tag on at the weekend or something like
that and we did do it during the weekend
originally
yeah yeah yeah yeah
20 30 minutes sometimes we do it live
sometimes we'd have to record it
beforehand and then we're like
everyone loved to vote on it everyone
loved
crazy democracy people like so so we
were like well let's just take this and
put this in friday afternoon our friday
in the second segment
that way we can have it and now bone in
a week lives in a replay on the midas
touch network
every single week yeah so it's it's it's
getting it's it's clearly getting eight
legs and i tell you
we've got and we've gained so many
audience members this week and it's just
week after week after week more and more
people are coming here to participate in
pro-democracy speech and that's what
they want to hear i really do believe
that folks in this country are
pro-democracy they want to lean into
democracy they want to engage in their
ballot they want to support
pro-democracy speech if you want to
support this show you can do that by
going support that
support.tonymichaelspod.com the link is
right down below or in the description
there's also a qr code you can use here
and you don't have to give money to
support i mean that would be great that
helps us out a lot me and gabe put a lot
of time and effort into this show it
helps so much for you guys
to give monetarily but you can also you
can also support by showing this show to
your your family your friends you can
spread around on social media go
subscribe to all of our channels not
just youtube but also go and subscribe
to every single one of your favorite
directories and download every single
episode and give us a rating over there
that helps us out a lot but you know the
thing that you can do the most that's
the most one
is follow us on twitter because we're
putting up a lot of new clips a lot of
news clips are coming out at tony
michael's pod so don't forget to go over
there and follow us for all those news
clips
and
really what you should do is watch us
every single weekday yeah i know that'll
be great that would be great two hours
the whole two hours monday through
friday noon eastern eleven central nine
pacific
on youtube twitter and twitch and
simulcasting from and we're also books
yeah and we're also now
cutting shorter clips from the show
because we because we know we know right
two hours is a lot of time for people
especially everyone's at work and
whatnot so if you don't have the ability
to watch the whole thing we're clipping
out smaller segments uh like we did
yesterday and the day before we have
some more stuff it's like it's like a
tony michael's podcast appetizer yeah
yeah you're like let me nibble let me
nibble i guess i don't have time to eat
the whole nine course ten course meal
right and just take the appetizers right
take it again
the salsa the souls
everyone everyone have a great weekend
be safe come back next week on monday
same time same place
surf's up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking